well well well look who is brave enough
to show his face in europe
say the word leslie i'll sick my army of
lions on them okay look i think um
things are starting to get a little out
of control here i agree you betrayed me
and you went behind my back and now you
need to pay
i need to i need to pay do i stutter oh
okay fair enough oh you know what you
might want to borrow this ew no one
wants your dirty underwear it's not
dirty underwear it's a white flag and
you may as well start waving it right
now
i will be waving is your decapitated
head on a stick in front of your weeping
mother
good lord
oh my god everything in my life is going
wrong right now whose fault is this i
demand to know actually ben thinks that
i'm a steamroller that's unbelievable
how dare he think that i'm a steamroller
leslie i'm just talking i know he's
going through a phase right now and
eventually we're going to both be
friends again no what i was going to say
is that you really are working too hard
i know ann you you keep starting all
these sentences and not finished you're
a steamroller
you're a massive enormous runaway
steamroller with no breaks and a cement
brick on the gas pedal you made me watch
all eight harry potter movies i don't
even like harry potter that's insane you
love harry potter you've seen all eight
movies when we go out to a bar you order
my drinks for me because you order white
wine and it gives you a headache what's
my headache
leslie
you do what you want you ignore what
other people want and you hear only what
you want to hear
okay i know
i know i do this
i'm the worst
no you're
very passionate you just push too hard
sometimes well then you should call me a
bulldozer rather than a steamroller
i'm sorry
it's gonna be okay
is it
honestly is it
i mean i guess i just need to leave ben
alone
that's what he says he wants
uh okay
well this steamroller is hanging up her
the
rolly thing on the front of the machine
what do you what do you call that roller
probably
okay
i know well that's the great thing about
treaties it doesn't even matter hey i'm
back
or as they say in denmark i'm back most
people speak english so are you guys
ready to polish off this treaty oh uh
actually i i merged our treaty with
russia and china's treaty
i got cut out of my own treaty yeah i
got sick of treading water so i swam
over to asia made a deal
the nation of denmark would like to
formally request a summit with the
nation of peru over there by the
refreshment table because the nation of
denmark needs a juice box
i am shocked and appalled by the actions
of the honorable delegate from peru
leslie just
look
i thought i could handle being friends
with you but i can't okay now we agreed
the other night that we can't spend time
together
i think that was the right call but that
was in a romantic way we can still spend
time together as friends
it doesn't work that way you can't just
chop up the aspects of a relationship
into discreet parts and select the ones
you want like a buffet
why not because it's selfish
stop being obtuse
look i understand where he's coming from
but i have been nothing but
straightforward with him and
if anyone in the entire world should
understand the difficult position i'm in
it's
it's just i've made an effort and i've
shared my flags with him and suddenly he
doesn't want to be friends
you know what that leaves me with only
one option plea just excuse me
attention this is an urgent world matter
due to a recent betrayal my homeland the
great state of denmark has officially
decided to declare war on peru
scandinavian brothers on my signal
unleash hell
having fun well four years of work down
the drain and i have a penis on my head
jam is stealing this lot right out from
under us my dream is dead anne mine two
this is why i prefer a nightmare you are
sad drinking right now and i need you to
be happy drinking like we watch grease
together i know anne but everything's
gonna disappear april's mini dog park
the little sebastian fountain even the
wamapoke playground yet another piece of
wamapoke land plowed over by the white
man just try to forget about it i mean
there's nothing you could do to stop
them tonight
for almost 200 years pawnee repeatedly
built factories restaurants and other
stuff on land held sacred by the
wamapoke people so we passed a law
saying that if any sacred wamapoke
artifact is found on a development site
all construction must immediately stop
it would be terrible if that were to
happen on this future ponchburger site
[Laughter]
oh this is bad
i should not have done this
one tiny critique if you do want to be
taken seriously you might want to think
a little bit about how you present
yourself oh no this is publicity for
oren's new performance art show he's an
animal living on a human farm and you
can go and feed him from your own hand
ugh that's horrifying and so is oren you
should not be friends with him so after
reviewing all the options i found that
the best location for the dog park is
lot 48
the one behind anne's house
no
no no no no no no no i've been trying to
put a park there for four years
see the thing is april that lot is mine
yeah i've been doing slow painstaking
work so
i don't want to whip out the legalese on
you now but i got dibs what we are gonna
do is we're gonna take your enthusiasm
we're gonna bundle it up and we're gonna
find a new place for a dog park doesn't
that sound fun one two three cheese good
girl
okay this is insane it is 40 degrees and
we are standing in freezing water no
this is our motivation we are not
leaving this fountain until we figured
this out once and for all fine why are
you not supporting me on this i thought
you agreed with me i do as a person but
as city manager i'm not 100 sure you
have a case you're not listening to my
side i mean sometimes when we disagree
you're so passionate i feel like i'm
arguing with the sun what that is
totally crazy i am super chill all the
time
i'm not mad that you're doing this yes i
am mad that you're doing this but even
worse i'm mad that you just lied to me
about it i'm sorry we all swore that we
weren't gonna ever help her again ever i
never said that you did i speak for all
of us in all matters that is what you
tacitly agreed to when you married me
what yeah let's go you've changed your
mind you're not going to help her
anymore i just want to borrow your
husband for the evening
oh hey we're up to 60 not bad right yes
and bad you might not care about jerry's
future but i do okay we need to do
something very drastic so he can be
happy so we can all be happy
okay uh are you thinking what i'm
thinking don't know what you're thinking
but i'm definitely not thinking what
you're thinking good idea anne okay we
have a new item up for bid a wonderful
surprise item an evening with sexy nurse
ann perkins
no yes look at her folks one evening
with the most beautiful woman in the
world just dinner and dancing nothing
sexual unless she's into that but no
she's not nothing fresh don't even try
it but you never know right no no she's
not into it don't try anything but you
know give it a shot either way it's for
a good cause let's raise some money
oh boy i know how this goes i know how
shauna operates she smiles and then they
fall in love and then they get married
and then she changes her name to shauna
malway wyatt or he's going to be really
progressive and change his name to ben
wyatt mall way tweep cut i am so annoyed
that he would hypothetically do that i'm
gonna remind you that the reason you're
not dating him is because you decided to
run for city council oh so just because
i can't go out with him someone else can
oh boy wow okay oh my god i just thought
of an idea of how we can save the parks
department
great let me ask you one question would
you be cool doing things that a
prostitute does
uh
minus the money
definitely yes then thanks ann
we're barely able to function we could
really use that money
well you know i don't know if it's
because i'm in such a good mood or
because of the charming and perkins but
i am going to seriously consider that
really that's great mission accomplished
let's boogie mission accomplished
uh-oh
yeah
there's a mission uh that dan had
thought of
it was both of our ideas but it was
mostly ann's
we
i had mentioned to anne that it would be
fun if you two went on a date so then
you could uh talk about the money and
then you know maybe give it to me
wow
i've just had my first
bad date
in perkins
not that sneaky
you